i mean  do you men do you guys care about a  girl's money  no  well not this point but it's nice if you  have money in it yeah it's not just  don't be flashing in my face and saying  i don't need you i don't do this  like is is a woman's ceo like hot to you  yeah yeah i understand really  yeah independent really  because  i've always heard from guys that they  don't care about a girl's money so it's  interesting that you guys have the  opposite point of view it just depends  on the situation uh-huh so for example  like  if i'm older and i'm trying to get my  stuff together  and  she hasn't like for example isn't hasn't  been really ambitious  then why would i like go for her because  it's not really in like